okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p now
this is going to be a voicemail that
relates to a lot of online culture stuff
so if you're like a radio listener you
watch on free speech TV and you don't
know anything about this I envy you just
give me the next 90 seconds to do this
and then we're gonna move on there's an
online streamer named Stephen destiny
Bunnell ii he's a personal friend of
mine when I was in Los Angeles we went
to dinner along with a couple other
people very nice guy personally he
streams a lot of political debates video
games whatever he's been around for a
while I've had him on the show after the
democratic debate last week we appeared
on each other's channels and we had a
conversation a couple people including
this caller is furious furious that I
appear as he says smitten with destiny
take a listen to this hello David this
is Chuck from California Oh David David
David come on man why are you smitten
with Stephen Bonnell the second or aka
destiny do you realize destiny passes
these students Q's knees throws out
these very dismissive criticisms of
progressives and he kisses her kisses up
to or rather supports people like John
Delaney if you listen to some of his
arguments he's very pro-corporate
he's a very anti less anti-progressive
he is anti universal medicare for all
single-payer health care do you not know
this about him listen this is just a
friend of mine right I I have friends
and we disagree about abortion I have
friends and we disagree about God I have
friends and we disagree about the best
path forward for Medicare the idea that
I mean listen smitten is sort of just
it's a goof that that's nonsense but the
idea that there are these purity tests
or checkboxes or whatever I mean listen
I don't have friends who are out and out
why
nationalists I do have friends from
where I you know growing up in high
school who have unenlightened views
about race for example people have all
sorts of different friends and
acquaintances and this idea that you
shouldn't even talk to people who do
this or believe that or the other thing
you know the the the idea that I'm gonna
apologize because I talked to destiny is
absolutely ridiculous
and I hope that this type of stuff
doesn't but I don't really care what
parameters different people use to
decide who to associate with I have my
parameters and other people might have
others
my only concern and the reason I bring
it up on the show even when a lot of
people don't necessarily know who
destiny is or care about this this issue
is that to the extent that it can affect
our removal of Donald Trump or our
ability to win elections in the Senate
in the house at the local level
governor's mansions so on and so forth
that's where I worry about this type of
approach the how dare I even be friendly
with Stephen Bernal he's more
pro-corporate than I am come on guys
come on that this is this is not
productive we will have today a very
special bonus show where producer Pat
will explain what's going on with the
David Pakman show to people in the
audience because today is kind of a
weird show in some ways and you'll find
out about that on the bonus show and
then the next week of shows is also
going to be strange and bizarre in some
ways so on today's bonus show producer
Pat will fill you all in get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership or a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show